[Music]
there are so many eagles here
bald eagles are our national bird and
for most people in the u.s
they're a rare magnificent sighting but
for us it's just part of our daily lives
everybody in town has an eagle story
i'm carlin enlo born and raised in
alaska and i am the onalaska visitors
bureau executive director
even though our island is almost 80
miles long there are nearly 600 birds in
just a few square miles
which is crazy there's an unnatural
amount of birds here because
we contribute to their food source these
bald eagles are so amazing and we love
seeing them but when they're involved in
your daily life they can make
running errands or your work really
difficult
doing something as simple as mailing a
letter can be dangerous
i'm officer wood with the onalaska
department of public safety
our department put up these signs to
warn the community about the
dangers of the nesting eagles which are
right next to the post office
eagles have been known to swoop down and
attack people they're very territorial
and they're just trying to protect their
nests
the eagles nest is right there and here
is the post office
some people have been hurt during these
incidents but i've also heard some funny
stories
i'm pam oss and i run bingo here
at the senior center every other sunday
i was carrying this box it had some of
my bingo stuff in it
all of a sudden a wing hit my head the
talons came down
grabbed the box and flew down the street
and i never saw my bingo box again
but if you want to see a whole lot of
eagles you go to the landfill
i'm steve bastick i work at the city of
onalaska landfill
one of my favorite places to be also one
of the eagles favorite places to be
i know that eagles are scavengers and
predators
so they like trash too they'll pick at
whatever they think might be food
my name is bob wilson i've been fishing
out of the bering sea in dutch harbor
for 40 years
dutch harbor is one of the largest
fishing ports in the world
[Music]
every time we pull in we know the eagles
are waiting for us so they can steal our
fish as we offload it
[Music]
do i think they're pests oh absolutely
but they're cool pests so that's okay
they make a mess of my boat which is
kind of the bad part
but they are national burden we love
them anyway
how's that
you